- The only way to
get out of it is,
well, it's not the only way,
the best way or
one of the key ways
is disseminate
what we stand for.
Which is why there's PragerU,
which is why I'm writing
The Rational Bible,
which is why you do what you do.
That is why, by the way,
they try to shove us down.
They know we can undo.
Why is it a big deal if you go
to a college campus or I do,
or Ben Shapiro or Jordan
Peterson or Candace Owens?
Why do they give a damn?
They have four years
to indoctrinate.
We get a 90 minutes because
they know in their heart
we can undo four
years in 90 minutes.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the founder of PragerU,
as well as the author
of the brand new book,
"The Rational Bible:
Deuteronomy, God,
Blessings and Curses"
Dennis Prager, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- I love being with
you. Great to be there.
- Dennis, I am always
happy to talk to you.
My first question
is, you've written,
according to my
research, 3,501 books,
this is your 2477th appearance
on the Rubin Report.
Which one of those would you say
is a higher accolade for you?
- If they were to put
one on my tombstone,
it will definitely be the
Rubin Report appearances.
When you weigh, I
mean, think about it,
you weigh the Bible and
then the Dave Rubin report.
Come on. Come on.
- Come on.
How many books is
this for you for real?
I mean, this has gotta be-
- You know what, this
is very interesting.
I have no idea what
this will say about me,
positive, negative, or neither.
I don't know how many
books I've written,
but I do know exactly how
many countries I have visited.
- How many countries
have you visited?
- 131.
- Wow.
- Slovakia was my
131st last year.
- What's remaining for you?
I mean, do you have anything
that you haven't gotten to yet?
- It's getting tough.
Rwanda, haven't been to Rwanda,
haven't been to Mongolia.
I've been to 20
African countries,
but I think there were 40.
- I've been on my mission to
get you to move to Florida,
but I see Rwanda
is in your heart.
- That is very funny.
Rwanda was for a visit.
Florida.
Hey, by the way, are you
worried about the hurricane?
- So as we're recording
this right now,
you know, I'm in Miami,
so it looks like it hit the
West Coast unbelievably hard.
Like category five.
My folks have a place over there
that we're just praying
isn't gonna be destroyed.
- Oh, God.
- But to bring it to a
little bit of the politics
and then we'll
get into the book.
I mean, DeSantis is doing
everything possible,
but the media's just waiting.
Are you feeling that?
Were you talking about that on
your radio show this morning,
that the media is just waiting
for one disaster to really
strike so they can say,
this is the thing
and he's incompetent
and he's evil and awful.
And like they would love
for destruction basically,
is what I'm saying.
- I want you to know that it
is not easy for me to say,
I agree with you in this case.
I think the left hatred
of us is so great
that a certain amount of joy
would be in their hearts.
They wouldn't express it, of
course, if Florida were hurt.
And by the way, I don't
think it's symmetrical.
I loathe what the
Democrats have done
to where I still
live in California.
It would bring me no joy
if some natural
disaster hit California.
I don't think there's
symmetry in the hatreds.
- Well that symmetry or
that asymmetry as you put,
that's sort of connected
to what this book is about
because it's about
God and the Bible
and goodness and
things of that nature.
And you know that I'm sort of,
as I sort of call
you, you're my "rabbi"
and we're actually taping this
right in between Rosh
Hashanah and Yom Kippur.
So this is an important
week for the Jewish people
to reflect on life
and all that stuff.
And you've reconnected me
with a lot of these things.
There's a reason for
that asymmetry, I think,
that politics is
their worldview, while
generally speaking,
more conservative,
leaning people,
and I don't mean that purely
in a conservative sense,
politically, but
conservative leaning people
have another ideology.
So it does make sense, right.
- I would go further.
We have another life.
It's so interesting you
should mention that.
So I think, you know,
but I'm sure most of your
viewers don't, or listeners.
I have been conducting the
Jewish High Holiday services
as if I were a rabbi,
I'm not ordained.
But as so to speak, a
rabbi, for 15 years,
this was the 15th year.
About 400 people attend.
Oh, you've attended actually.
- I've been many times.
Actually the first
time I was there
was about four years ago or so.
You were giving the sermon
and you were discussing
something about
same sex couples,
and you referenced David and I
being dinner at our
house a few days before.
You didn't even
know I was there.
- I did not even know you
were there. That's right.
- But I've been many times
and it's standing room only
and it's wonderful what
you do, ordained or not.
- Yeah, exactly.
So I want to comment on your
point about the different life.
So first, by the way, I just
want for those interested,
they can watch my
service anytime they
want till January 1st
now or anytime at salemnow.com.
Just so they should know that.
- And the music is
incredible by the way.
You get people the LA, from
Harmonic and all sorts of stuff.
- I don't know, it's
the whole thing.
I explain everything.
Non-Jews watch it
even more than Jews do
cause there are a lot
more non-Jews than Jews.
But it appeals to everybody.
So anyway, I actually
noted on my show
when I returned from
my two day break,
how important it is in my
life that I have another life,
a life of religion.
And when one doesn't have that
and everything,
everything is secular,
there is a real danger that,
and this is the danger
of the left part of it.
Everything is then
politics, everything.
The purpose of your
life, the meaning.
It's your interest,
it's your passion.
It's not my interest.
It's not my passion.
I'm passionate about the
ultimate questions of life,
which is why I'm writing
my Bible commentary.
Because if people understand
the first five books,
which are by far the most
important in all of the Bible,
Jesus would've said that
as Jesus and as a Jew,
which he was,
the most important books
actually ever written.
You will find this fascinating.
I just learned this sadly
after I'd already
completed Deuteronomy,
it's the fifth book,
but it's my third,
I didn't go in order.
And you will find as
fascinating as I did.
The founders of the
country cited Deuteronomy
more than any other
religious or secular work
in their writings and
in their speeches.
That's how much
this book influenced
the creation of the
freest country ever made.
And so that should
be, if one needs one,
and I think does one need one,
most people never
heard of Deuteronomy.
But it is a phenomenal
work of the five books.
It's Moses' summary
of everything.
This is realites, this
humanity is what is important.
I'll give you one example.
So I wrote a column for Fox
giving seven great insights
just from the book.
Do not show partiality
in judgment.
There is a specific law in
both Exodus and Deuteronomy,
you cannot, it's specific.
You'll love this Dave.
You cannot favor the poor man
who comes into your court.
Justice is justice.
It is like a law
against social justice.
There is only justice.
- It's basically, it's
a law against equity.
That's sort of-
- Exactly.
Equity and justice are
mutually exclusive.
Equity and liberty are
That's exactly right.
- Give me one more
that's in that column.
- Okay, so another one here.
So do not be afraid of anyone.
Only fear God.
Fear of God is the
antidote to fear of man.
I know it cause it's
operative in my life.
I don't give a damn
about what the New York
Times writes about me.
It means nothing. I sleep
perfectly fine that night.
I don't walk around
fearing anyone.
And you don't know how
liberating that is.
That is why one of the
three models of the country
is in God we trust, not we
trust will take care of us.
It's God who matters.
And of course man
matters obviously,
but not in terms of fear.
If you don't fear God,
you will fear man.
Humans fear. It is
part of our makeup.
It is impossible
not to have fears,
but you can liberate
yourself from it
if you fear the right
party, which is God.
I'll give you another one.
- Let me just ask you something
on that before you continue.
Did did you always
have that within you?
I mean, I think
you've always had it
as for the now eight or so
years that I've known you.
And people know this story.
But at the height of COVID
when I dragged you
out to a Trump rally
and you literally said to me,
unvaxxed you and unvaxxed me,
"I hope I get COVID here."
And then of course the media
all called for you to die
and you eventually did get
COVID and you survived,
much to their chagrin.
But the point is, you weren't
being dominated by fear.
Was that always in you
or was that something
you learned very early?
- Yeah, I learned
it and imbibed it.
It became part of my nature.
By the way, I just
wanna make clear,
it was partially tongue in
cheek about wanting COVID.
What I did want was a
way to get antibodies.
- Yes, you said that, for sure.
- And you know, I'm
not an idiot obviously,
but I turned out right.
I turned out right when
I said that the lockdowns
were the greatest international
mistaken human history.
And they were, they
were devastating.
Keeping kids outta school
for two years was a crime.
Literally a crime.
It was a crime against children.
You know, look, we
both feel this way.
I don't have to
belabor the point,
but let's put it this way.
I wrote a piece
about 20 years ago,
How the left keeps me religious.
You'd love it. You should
take a look at that.
- That might explain my
religious revival over here.
- Yes, of course it would.
I have been honest enough to
say, if the anti-religious left
and the left is anti-religious,
from Lennon to Soros,
if the left had produced kind,
intelligent, wise people,
my religious beliefs
would've been challenged.
I fully acknowledge it,
because I judge ideologies
by their product.
And that's why I don't
judge people's theology
or philosophy.
But the left is wrong on
everything, ruins everything.
And most of them aren't nice.
I'm not talking liberals, you
know, I make a distinction.
Liberals are weak,
but they're not bad.
- You know, it's interesting
because as you know,
we just had Justin
a couple weeks ago
and we've got number two,
baby number two on the way.
But we did the
briss at eight days.
And you know, if you look at it
from a purely secular
point of view,
it's somewhat of a
crazy thing to do.
You bring this perfect
thing into the world
and then you're
cutting this child,
that's what you're doing.
And I remember David and I
had this talk before about,
you know, our thoughts
on everything.
And my overriding feeling
about it was that,
my parents did it,
their parents did it,
their parents parents
did it, and way beyond.
- That's right.
- For something
like 5,783 years.
- 3000. Well really 3,200.
- Yes.
- Or 4,000, actually
4,000 if you go back-
- The calendar but we go
back to Abraham. Okay.
But the point is that it's been
done for a long, long time.
And I felt that that,
am I just wiser than
everyone that came before me?
- Oh God bless you.
Oh, that's so the
perfect reaction.
And that's what they believe.
- They think they are. Yeah.
- Leftists believe they are
the best people who ever lived.
They do.
That's why they tear down
Lincoln and Washington.
We are better than them.
They don't hold a
candle to these people.
By the way, I just
want you to know,
I have two sons as
you'll have, God willing.
I don't cry easily.
And the two times I
most remember sobbing
was at their briss,
at their circumcision,
exactly for what you said.
Holy crow, this goes
back 4,000 years.
I'm not prepared to end it.
- It just felt crazy to me.
Like, no, I just know so much.
I just know so much,
I won't do this thing.
The people before
me were so dumb.
It's almost grotesque in a
bizarre sense to think that way.
But do you think that that,
so you are writing this book
as all of this COVID
craziness is going down.
And you're, you're making
this distinction between,
you know, politics and
having a religious worldview
or just something
that's not politics.
And then you see the people
in the name of science
sort of become, I
wouldn't say religious,
they became cult-like in
their following of this stuff.
That must have been interesting
to be writing this
at the same time.
- All it did is reinforce
everything I was writing
and everything.
Do you know that there's
another law in the Torah,
to give you an idea of how
contemporaneous this stuff is.
Do not follow the
majority to do bad.
- Could have put that
one on Twitter, Dennis.
- Is that mind blowing.
A biblical law?
- Do you think somehow
that religious people
didn't sell this
stuff well enough?
Like what do you
think happened here?
- Correct. You're right.
You hit it, Dave, you're so
in touch with everything.
It cracks me up.
Talking to you is such a joy.
- Likewise my friend.
- Thank you. That
is exactly correct.
The religious are as
responsible for the rampant
non-religiosity as an
anti-religious are.
That is exactly correct.
- Do you think that
goes across religions
from a western sense at least?
- Oh completely.
Christians fail to
teach religion properly.
Jews fail to teach
religion properly.
They all relied on inertia.
I'm religious, my kid will
be religious. End of issue.
By the way Americans
did it as Americans.
Americans didn't sell
America to their kids.
And that's another
law in Deuteronomy.
You have to teach these things
diligently to your children.
When you wake up,
when you go to bed,
when you walk by the
way, these are all,
it's so brilliant.
You can't stop.
And it's perfect to tell
you cause you're gonna have,
you have one and a half
or one and three quarters.
Dave, you guys gotta
talk to your kids
about values constantly.
I know I drove my kids
crazy. I had one message.
I don't give a damn
about your grades.
All I care about is your
character. Have a great day.
- And your kids are pretty good.
I know David particularly.
- Yes, that's correct.
That's correct.
And they play that recording.
By the way, my older son, whom
you know better also David,
the one straight
David at the table.
- You love that, you love
when it's the five of us,
there's one straight David.
- I gotta say, he cracks me,
he cracks me up
in general David.
But he has one
complaint against me.
You're gonna love this,
cause if you don't have a
complaint against your father,
you're not normal.
So he has one complaint
that I know of. Okay?
I can't speak about others
that I don't know of.
Dad, you didn't push me
hard enough in school.
And he's right. I didn't.
In fact, I said, I don't
care if you do your homework.
I care about your character.
Very few parents say that,
but I'll tell you something,
you get better character.
- All right, Dennis.
Now I'm gonna ask you the
hardest question I can ask you
because you gave me
the perfect segue,
which is the thing that
my mom often says to me.
She says, "I know you've
become good friends
with Dennis Prager.
And, you know, I agree
with Dennis Prager
on a lot of things, but he
always talks about character,
how important character is.
But he voted for Donald Trump.
He supports Donald Trump."
Talk to my mother, Dennis.
- I have an answer
to your mother.
Mom, God forbid you or
a loved one has cancer.
I got two oncologists for you.
One with great character,
one with a
compromised character,
but who treats cancer better.
Which would you go to?
You don't choose
everybody on character.
You choose a leader
on what he will do,
or she will do, as the case
may be, for your country,
whether they are kind or
monogamous or whatever,
that is between them and
their spouse and God,
between me and them.
John F. Kennedy had
orgys in the White House.
In my opinion, incidentally,
this is truly incidentally,
I believe that Joe
Biden's character
is so much more deficient
than Donald Trump.
They won't even end up in the
same place in the hereafter.
They won't be neighbors.
Nevertheless, it
doesn't matter to me.
I don't vote for president
based on what I perceive
as their character.
America is more important to me
than whether Donald Trump
slept with a porn star.
that is of no interest
to me whatsoever.
It's of interest to
me if my son does it,
but I'm not voting
for him for president.
- Was that a hard one for you
to sell a couple years back
for your audience that's
known you for so long
and talking about something.
- Hey, listen, I
wrote a piece called
"Adultery and
Politicians" 25 years ago.
It's in print in my
book of essays from 1998
called "Think a Second Time".
"Adultery and Politicians".
I don't give a damn
if a politician
was faithful or not to his wife.
- So you've been pretty
consistent on this.
- I've been very
consistent. That's right.
- All right, so let's-
- The only thing I didn't
know since high school,
I don't mean, I've
learned a ton,
but the only big thing I didn't
realize till Ronald Reagan,
that's when I
became a Republican,
the truth of his
great one sentence,
"the government is not the
solution, it's the problem."
In one sentence.
People say, how can you get
so much done in five minutes
in a PragerU video?
It doesn't take five minutes.
A truth can take one sentence.
Government is the
problem, not the solution.
He was entirely wrong.
- Was it Reagan also?
- I learned that-
- Wasn't it Reagan also,
the worst eight words
you can hear in the
English language.
I'm here from the government,
I'm from the government and
I'm here to help, right?
I mean.
(Dennis claps)
- Exactly correct.
- That's pretty good. Speaking
of PragerU real quick,
little sidebar.
You guys are about to put up
your 500th five minute video.
I've done four of those.
Would you say they're
the four best?
- Oh, there's no close third.
- I mean, it's pretty
amazing what you built,
you know, you and Allen.
You just had, or he, I guess
had the original idea sort of.
I've heard you talk
about it a little bit.
- He had the original idea in
the Indian Ocean, I might add.
- And you put this thing
together and now every day
the New York Times is
running hit pieces on you.
- Well, you know, my
favorite, you will love this.
I don't know if you know this.
Front page New York Times
last month, an attack on,
who was, oh on Elon Musk.
And in the front bay of
the front page it said,
"he must be watching
PragerU videos."
(laughs)
I loved it.
You don't know much fundraising
we did on that line.
- Yeah, I bet, I bet.
- Yes, exactly.
- 500 videos, it's
pretty impressive.
But wait, I wanna circle back.
So do you wanna go into some
of the other, the seven.
I was gonna jump to
some other things,
but I feel like you
can basically interview
yourself here.
- I just wanna make something
clear to your viewers.
The most important
thing in life is wisdom.
Good intentions don't mean
crap, may mean nothing.
The amount of evil done by
people with good intentions
is greater than the amount
of evil done by sadists.
So if you think you're good
cause you have good intentions,
join the list of people
who haven't done any good.
You need wisdom to
make a better world
and to make a better
character for yourself.
These five books are wisdom
, about every aspect of life.
I am so in love with the
Torah, the first five books.
And thank God I
know them in Hebrew
cause obviously I don't
think I could have done this
without knowing the Hebrew.
I am so in love with it
that you'll find this,
you who are making
your way gradually
to a less secular life,
you'll find this of interest.
And I say this now
a lot in speeches.
I don't believe in the Torah
because I believe in God.
I believe in God because
I believe in the Torah.
My vehicle to belief
in God is rational.
It's why my series is
called The Rational Bible.
This is the third of
five of those books.
My vehicle to God
is not miracles,
is not visions, is not emotion.
It is, and I'm not saying
everyone's vehicle,
but mine is reason.
The Torah is my
rational vehicle to God.
And I make that case in
each of these volumes.
So I gave you example
of those two laws.
Here's another one. Let's see.
Oh God, you shall, okay.
The 10 Commandments is
repeated in Deuteronomy.
God says it in Exodus and Moses
repeats it in Deuteronomy.
And Deuteronomy means
in Greek, second law.
So this is Moses
reviewing everything.
So one of them is, of course,
you shall have no other gods.
And I point out in both
Exodus and Deuteronomy,
we have more gods today
than any ancient pagan had.
When you think of the false gods
that people believe in today,
you know, and I go through them.
Like just one example, science.
I believe in science.
And I go, what the
hell does that mean?
Does science tell
you to be kind?
you to be honest?
Does science tell you to marry?
Does science tell
you to have children?
you to be courageous?
Science tells you nothing.
It tells you science.
- You can also ask
the science people,
they believe in science.
Then ask them if
boys can become girls
and they get quiet real quick.
- That's right.
That's exactly right.
Exactly right.
This was science.
It was science not to
have kids in school.
Sweet had kids in school every
single day, not one died.
That wasn't science, that
was scared scientists
who were worthless and harmful.
- So do you connect that-
- There's a big difference
between scientists and science.
- So do you connect that to
what we talked about earlier,
that in a weird way,
people need to believe
whether they
believe that or not.
So that whether they
think they have to or not,
they end up believing
in something.
Thus the secularists
just, or the progressives,
whatever you wanna call them,
they just pick the different
set of beliefs, period.
- That is exact. Yes, exactly.
You know, Mother Earth, I
don't believe in Mother Earth.
But I believe the earth
was created by God
for humans to use.
Not abuse, but use, okay?
Humans are more
important than trees,
more important than apes.
That is my human centered,
divinely given belief.
That's just another example.
So which do you believe?
Are the humans a curse on earth
or are the humans
to control earth
for the good of
the human species?
I believe the latter.
Yes, go on.
- Well, do you sense that
over the last couple years,
because of the COVID craziness
and the way our
politics has become,
you know, cult-like,
or whatever,
that people are waking up
to something more rational.
Maybe they're not saying,
okay, I'm ready to make
that leap of faith yet,
a certain set of people,
but that there is
something happening.
You know, it's like if
you're gonna tell people
that their sons are
their daughters,
they might go, you know,
maybe some of that
old stuff in the Torah
or some of those other
old books is pretty good.
- If they're exposed to
it, which is my dream.
I have 4,000 reviews.
By the way, when
"Exodus" came out,
it was the number
two book on Amazon,
which is astonishing for a
Bible commentary, you know?
- Why do you write them
in a different order?
- I be totally honest, I
wrote them in the order
that I thought would appeal to
people to get them involved.
If I started with Deuteronomy,
nobody would know what
the hell I was doing.
But everybody heard of Exodus
and everybody heard of Genesis.
So I started with the two
most widely known books.
And I'm working my way through.
I mean, when I get to Leviticus,
if you asked the average,
I believe this truly.
If you went on Harvard
campus and said to a kid,
Hey, do you know
what Leviticus is?
He would probably say no.
I said, well, Leviticus
is the favorite horse
in the Kentucky Derby?
They go, no kidding.
- They love Leviticus.
- Yeah Leviticus.
Oh man, Leviticus fan Club.
- Win the Triple Crown.
Wait, I wanna back up to,
as I've jotted down
a couple notes here,
I usually don't have to jot
down notes for an interview,
much less with a friend.
But there's so
much going on here
that I actually did
write a few things down.
And obviously, you do this all
the time on your radio show
and everywhere else, you
talk about goodness so much.
And you connect that
really to the Torah,
that it's not just knowledge
or wisdom as you would put it,
but goodness is
also baked in there.
and it doesn't seem like we
have a lot of that right now.
- So my underlying belief
and that of the Torah
is that God wants
people to be good.
That is why, and it's
one of the reasons
that I am in love
with the Torah,
it makes clear you
don't have to be a Jew
for God to reward you.
You can be a pagan, you can be,
obviously they didn't exist
then, but later a Christian,
you could be anything.
God judges your behavior,
not your theology.
And that is one of
the greatest lessons.
It's called ethical monotheism.
It is my fundamental belief.
If one wants to become a Jew,
one is more than welcome.
But the Jewish
belief is not that
you have to be a
Jew to be saved.
You have to be a good person.
Nobody is perfect. I
said good, not perfect.
God made us flawed. And so we
have to do the best we can.
You wanna do the best you
can, you have to learn wisdom.
You can't be a good
person if you're a fool.
That's the basic
fundamental understanding.
And in order to gain wisdom,
you have to study wisdom.
That's why I wrote a
column a few weeks ago.
I had more wisdom,
and so did all the kids
in my class at Yeshiva,
than 90% of today's
college professors.
Again, when I was
15, I had more wisdom
and so did my other
Yeshiva classmates
and so did Christian kids in
traditional Christian schools
than 90% of the professors
in America today.
We studied wisdom,
we understood.
For example, we knew
that people's nature
is not basically good.
And the average
professor probably thinks
human nature is basically good,
which is the beginning
of foolishness.
You can't have a
coherent worldview
if you think human nature
is essentially good.
- Is that also why
politics is so screwy
that we have a bunch of people
who just wanna take advantage
of people who are not wise?
I mean, if you just turn on,
you turn on almost,
almost anything,
and it's like, man,
you'd have to be pretty unwise
to be buying any
of this nonsense
from mainstream
media these days.
- Yeah, well, but the point is
it's the unwise
leading the unwise.
It's not like they're wise and
they're fooling the unwise.
Is Gavin Newsom a wise man?
- My audience knows my feelings.
- Is Lori Lightfoot
a wise woman?
I mean, but wisdom is
invalued, it isn't taught.
That's why these books
that I'm writing,
I think are so
incredibly important.
Look, nobody writes a Bible
commentary to get rich.
I'm writing it because this is
my legacy of my life's work.
People need to understand
the greatest five
books ever written.
And that's what this project
is called, "The Rational Bible".
- I should mention
that actually.
Last time I saw you was
just a couple weeks ago
with Jordan Peterson.
And you were in town
because you were doing,
correct me,
- That's right, exodus.
- You were doing
his biblical series.
Oh, so you went through
Exodus with him.
- Yeah, and we're going to...
Well, and we only
got through half
and we're gonna
do the other half.
By the way, you'll get
a kick out of this.
So he invited five of
us, five or six of us,
you know, with the Daily Wire.
It's a beautiful project
and I was delighted
to be part of it.
He wrote to me
something to the effect,
I'm really glad you were there.
We needed somebody
to make us laugh.
I realized, I realized-
- He meant you. I
think he meant you.
- I don't know if I should even-
- I think he meant you.
- What?
- That's what the Jews
are supposed to do.
- Yeah. I guess so.
It was very fun.
I realized within the
first hour, uh oh,
if I don't start saying
some really silly things,
we're doomed.
- When you have these talks.
So I wasn't with
you guys that night,
but I was with that whole
crew, the biblical crew
a night or two at later.
When you're with all
these people and you're,
I think you were the only one
coming at it from a
Jewish perspective,
but then there were obviously
Christians and Catholics
and all sorts of other things.
Do you find that there are
really places of divergence
that can't be sort
of accommodated
or that you can't walk away
and all be kind of okay?
- It all depends on
the Christian I'm with.
I mean, for example,
Os Guinness, who I
fell in love with,
he was one of the others.
The guy, he has
written about 30 books,
which is three times
more than I've written.
For all intents and purposes,
he was like a fellow Jew
in terms of thought
and theology.
Of course he believes in
Christ, he's a Christian.
But otherwise, he was
my ally on every point,
and most of them would be.
There was much
greater difference
between a conservative
and a left wing Jew,
than between a conservative Jew
and a conservative Christian,
or a liberal Jew and
a liberal Christian.
The divergence today is right,
left, not Christian, Jew.
- Yeah.
And that divergence doesn't
seem to be going anywhere
from the political scene.
- No.
Well, no, it's not
just political,
social, philosophical, moral.
We have nothing in common.
Left and right have
nothing in common.
I say this with sadness, but
I live in the real world.
- So how do we get outta that?
How do we get outta that?
- The only way to
get out of it is,
well, it's not the only way.
The best way or
one of the key ways
is disseminate
what we stand for.
Which is why there's PragerU,
which is why I'm writing
"The Rational Bible",
which is why you do what you do.
That is why, by the way,
they try to shut us down.
They know we can undo.
Why is it a big deal if you go
to a college campus or I do,
or Ben Shapiro or Jordan
Peterson or Candace Owens.
Why did they give a damn.
They have four years
to indoctrinate.
We get at 90 minutes.
Because they know in their heart
we can undo four
years in 90 minutes.
- That's good.
Sometimes we can undo four
years in five minutes.
That's even better.
- That's right. Hence
the PragerU videos.
- That's even better.
Let's dive into a couple
of the other pieces here.
Chapter 13 is Why
would God test us?
This is obviously one
that you've been asked
in a million forums
on every probably radio
show you've ever done.
Why would God...
Shouldn't things just
be a little bit easier?
Come on, there's
God, he's moral.
We're trying to be good.
Couldn't he just take it
easy on us just a little bit?
Why do bad things happen
to good people, Dennis?
- Well, those are two
separate questions,
bad things happening to
good people and testing us.
I don't regard all
suffering as a divine test
because it will imply that
if your kid has cancer,
God gave your kid cancer.
And I don't believe
that for a second.
God created a world where
bad things can happen.
And my best answer to
this question which is
I've been absorbed with all
of my life since high school.
I heard a statement from
a rabbi Milton Steinberg.
And I think he said it, I didn't
hear it from him directly.
I read it. I love it.
He said the following,
"the believer in God has
to explain one thing,
the existence of
unjust suffering.
The atheist has to explain
the existence of
everything else."
I find that the best answer
I've ever heard to this problem.
I don't deny it's a
problem, unjust suffering.
I don't deny it.
But compared to what the
atheist has to explain,
literally everything else,
and for which he
has no explanation,
then I'm back to belief
in God with my question.
- And as they say,
we're in a multiverse,
that's what they always say.
We're in a multiverse,
anything's possible.
- You're right.
The only thing that's not
possible is a multiverse.
- That must be what believing
in one God is all about.
It just kind of keeps
you off the multiverse.
- Listen, just remember this,
and this should be a message
even to people like you.
And it is, I know, cause
you're now thinking that
maybe religion has
something important to say.
There were very few outliers
during the COVID hysteria
and almost all of them were
religious, Christian or Jew.
That's not insignificant.
If a place was gonna be open
and most, by the way, most
synagogues and churches,
I think failed
the test terribly.
They succumbed to secular
irrational authority
just like everybody else.
But those institutions
that didn't
were almost all religious.
It's like who rescued
Jews in the Holocaust?
Very few people.
But among them, overwhelmingly
they were religious people.
Most religious people
failed the test.
But of those who passed the
test, most were religious.
- That's basically
as high of credit
as you can give to
religion, I suppose.
When the chips fall.
- Not every religious
person is terrific,
but most terrific
people are religious.
- Chapter 34, I thought
this was really interesting
in light of politics
and something we kind
of discussed earlier.
People in positions of authority
should not seek to be loved.
This is on page 508.
It's a hefty book.
It seems like almost
everybody in politics
is there to be loved.
They do seem to love the line.
I would say not all.
I would say we have an
exception here in Florida
of a guy that's trying to just
do the good job that he's-
- That's right. He doesn't
care if he's loved.
- But most of them-
- So let me...
I'm so happy you picked on that.
The single Greatest crisis
has been the parental authority
crisis since World War II.
Parents decided that the
thing they wanted most
was that their kids loved them.
And that ended parenthood
and ended our society growth
as a moral society
building good people.
The moment a parent
wants to be loved,
that is the end of
their parenting.
The moment a political
leader wishes to be loved,
that is the end of their
validity as a political leader.
The moment the teacher
wants to be loved,
that is the end of
their teaching ability.
The only people we should
want to be loved from
are our spouses and
friends, end of issue.
- Well, I know somebody
is watching this thinking,
but wait a minute, Dennis,
I can accept what you said
on Trump related to the,
you know, whether he had sex
with other women or whatever.
But he does seem like
he wants to be loved.
- Trump?
- Yeah.
- If there's one thing,
even his enemies have to,
he loves to be loved
by his followers,
but as a general rule,
Trump has disdain.
- Oh, that's interesting.
So you're making a
distinction between sort of
someone who has, let's say,
followers or supporters
that love them
versus he's not going for
institutional love or something.
I mean, that's kind
of whittling it down.
But you think-
- Yes or exactly.
No, no, no.
You could say Trump loves Trump,
but that Trump does
what he does for love
given the swiftness with which
he will lash out at people.
He's the last person
I would accuse
of doing what he does for love.
- I got it. I got it.
But love comes along the
way when you do this.
Isn't that something?
When you do something that's
good and honest and true,
you get a lot of love.
I mean, I've been out
and about with you.
- Well, that is right.
That's the irony, isn't it?
If you act noble and
not in pursuit of love,
you will end up
with a lot of love.
So, you know, one of
the most common things
people say to me at airports
and restaurants say,
"Oh, you know, I just want
you to know I love you,
but ah, I'm sure you
hear it all the time."
So I go, "well, I
hear it all the time,
but on the other hand,
I'd like you to just Google
Dennis Prager asshole
and see how many hits you get."
- There's worse things
you could google
about either one
of us, I'm sure.
You know that actually-
- That is correct.
- That actually
reminds me of something
that I hope you don't
mind me bringing this up.
When Jordan and I and you
had dinner a couple weeks ago
and I was fortunate enough,
I don't know how many
people would trade
almost everything they got
to right before they're
about to be a father,
to sit down with Dennis
Prager and Jordan Peterson.
And one interesting
thing that we noticed
between the three of us is that,
if you don't mind me saying,
you are 74 years old.
Jordan is 60 and I'm 46.
So we have 14 years
between the three of us,
which was just sort of-
- Oh, that's interesting.
- It was just sort of
interesting to think about.
But you said something
when we were talking about
how to parent and teach the
children the right thing
and all this.
You said something
to the effect of how,
that whatever your
parents' faults were,
whatever you might look
back and fault them for,
that you said, but I turned
out to be a good moral person
so I can let all
of those things go.
I'm roughly paraphrasing.
- That's right.
- But I thought was
a really decent way
of moving forward in life
because everyone's got
issues with their parents,
but a lot of people are just
focused on them all day long.
- Which is why by the way,
another brilliance of the Torah.
We're instructed to honor our
parents but not to love them.
And we are told to
love the stranger,
to love God, to
love our neighbor,
but we're not told
to love our parents.
It realizes in its genius that
cannot be demanded of people.
It can be demanded of people
that they not dishonor
their parents.
This is why I tell you.
This is reason number 8566 why
I'm in love with the Torah.
- How do you square that
with people who just have,
you know, just generally
terrible parents.
I mean alcoholic, abusive,
neglectful et cetera, et cetera.
- That's right.
So I spoke about that on
my Rosh Hashanah service.
As a general rule, exceptions.
There's a rule in
law, what is it?
Bad cases make bad law.
Nothing can cover
every instance.
Do we all acknowledge that
we should stop at red lights?
Yes.
How about if the guy
next to you in the car,
your passenger
has a heart attack
and it's a matter of time
that you have to get
him to a hospital.
Will you go through a red
light if you can? Yes.
Will everybody justify it? Yes.
So we all understand there
are exceptions to rules,
but it takes a lot
and you just have to
answer to God for this.
It takes a lot to justify
not honoring a parent.
And I'll give an example.
You are not justified if
your parent voted for Trump
and you hate Trump.
You are a scumbag if you don't
talk to your father or mother
cause they voted for Trump,
you're just a lousy,
damn narcissistic kid
unworthy of anything positive
to be said about you.
And I would say that
to a conservative kid
who didn't vote for a
parent who voted for Biden,
but there doesn't
exist such a kid.
Cause if we
conservatives met a guy,
"Oh, I don't talk to my
father, he voted for Biden."
What are you, an a-hole?
But (indistinct) your
father, your schmuck.
- I do think about that a lot
where it's like, you know,
I had a chat with Bill Maher
on his podcast, two hour chat,
and I wanted to bring
up what happened
with you and him from a
couple months back on his show
where you basically
said, you know,
Google men menstruating.
And he kind of brushed it
off, but it's true now,
that is sort of a main
point of the left.
But now men can menstruate.
Okay, unfortunately
it didn't come up.
But I had a chat with him
and one of the things that we
were sort of dancing around
that I was trying to explain
to him in some ways was that,
if someone that's
conservative leaning
walks into a room
full of liberals,
you're gonna be berated or
ignored or treated horribly
or sneered at or something.
If a liberal or a lefty,
whatever you wanna
call it at this point,
walks into a room
of conservatives,
mostly they'll be super friendly
and then maybe they'll
turn around and be like,
"that guy's an idiot."
But it'll sort of be like,
it'll be like sort of a joke.
- That's right.
- My whole life is is
an example of that.
- That is exactly-
What is an example of that?
- Well, my life in a way that
I was in both those circles.
I know how they both
operate and when you meet,
if you're hanging out with,
you're having beers or whatever,
you're having drinks, whatever
smoking cigars, as you would
with a bunch of conservatives
and a liberal walks in,
everyone's curious about
why they think that way.
But the other way it's
like, why are you a Nazi?
- That's right. That's right.
I have nothing to add to
it. That is exactly correct.
It turns out we're nicer than
they are. That's the irony.
- But I thought we're
so scary, Dennis.
- I know.
Well, well we're scary
to them for some reason.
You know who gave
the reason in part?
The new prime minister of Italy.
- Wasn't that incredible?
What a speech.
- Those two minutes
summarized everything.
I will just say I wrote
this 20 years ago,
but it doesn't matter.
To hear it from an
Italian prime minister
brings me such joy.
When she said they hate the
fact that we have an identity.
I am a woman, I am a Christian,
I am an Italian,
and I am a mother.
It was so great.
I said this about George
Soros a long time ago.
George Soros has no identity.
He has no national identity
and he has no
religious identity.
And the people with no identity
hate the people who have one.
- And that really
almost sums up.
You said every, you know,
it's left first, tight?
But really that almost is it.
It's the people of the borg
of the collective identity
versus the people who
it's a little messy
cause you're not gonna believe,
they're gonna think about
things a little bit differently.
- Right.
- Are you hopeful, Dennis.
Are you hopeful for the
country and for the world?
Cause when I hang with
you, you're laughing.
You laugh more
than anyone I know.
You've got such a
boisterous laugh.
You're always
having a great time.
I see you with, when
fans come up to you,
I mean, you're
always having a ball.
But this is, you know,
it's not guaranteed
that this thing's gonna
get us to the other side
and people are gonna be better
and think better
and be more wise.
- So I have figured
out how to have a ball
as the building falls down.
I'm not saying it
will fall down,
but there are massive
cracks in the (indistinct).
I am not philosophically
an optimist.
I don't know how
any Jew could be,
given the amount of suffering,
given the fact that the
most advanced society,
culturally in the
world, Germany,
the place of Beethoven and
Bach and Shela and Gerta
produces Auschwitz.
Nobody expected it.
So I'm not a big optimist,
but I don't give a damn
about optimism or pessimism.
I only give a damn about
what do I have to do.
And if they died on Normandy
Beach at 20 years of age
for Liberty in America, I
could live for Liberty America.
And that's what I do.
And in the meantime,
I have a great time.
I love being at your house.
- Well, speaking of
being at my house,
we can end with this then.
When I left California,
you were at my table
for the last meal,
the last supper in California,
when I begged you
and Larry Elder
and a couple people to come.
I had you on my show
a couple months ago.
I reiterated the point.
I had you for dinner
here a couple weeks ago.
Sue was here, People
have been here.
What are you doing? What
are you doing at this point?
It's insulting.
- I tell everybody,
Dave Rubin sends my wife
and me every damn week,
another great house on
sale in his neighborhood.
- I'm on Zillow half the
day just sending Sue.
- Let me just tell you,
it does have an effect.
We're not moving yet,
but I need to tell you,
we scour that house, we
read everything about it.
- Dennis, all I'm
saying, all I'm saying is
the house across the street
from me, for sale, direct.
- I know.
- Imagine you could wake up
in the morning, cup of coffee,
I come over, we chat
about philosophy.
There's a tennis court,
Dennis, a tennis court.
- Oh God. I know.
The problem, as you know,
is the number of people
I love who are here,
including, I founded
a synagogue here,
which is very meaningful
to me every Sabbath,
and then I do my High Holidays.
So it's a tear.
I totally get why you
moved. I totally get it.
- Dennis, I-
- Anyway, I really hope
your people will get
"The Rational Bible"
the new volume.
I promise them it'll change
their life. I promise.
It's very powerful stuff.
- Well look, you've
changed my life
personally and professionally.
I mentioned to you at my
Passover Seder this past year,
we had the rational hagaddah,
where you can go through
the story of Passover
and get wisdom
not only from you,
but Jordan Peterson and some
other people in our circles.
I found it, it's a little
more, I would say edible
than maybe the old
Maxwell House hagaddah.
It started to age on
me a little, you know.
- Well, it's certainly richer.
- There's a coffee
joke there somewhere.
Dennis, I love you. I
hope to see you soon.
- It's mutual. Same here.
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations
about spirituality instead
of nonstop yelling,
check out our
spirituality playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.